Theodore Roosevelt leads the American
sieve in Sid Meier's Civilization six
the famous quote from the 26th President
of the United States speak softly and
carry a big stick
reflected his governing style he
championed the popular reforms of the
Progressive Era and a muscular foreign
policy backed by a reinvigorated US Navy
in Civilization six each civilization
has two abilities one is based on what
the nation has done throughout history
and the other is tailored to what
happened during the rulers reign the
American civil around Mother's which
shortens the time needed to earn
government legacy bonuses the Americans
also get the p-51 Mustang unique unit
with extended range and bonuses against
other fighter aircraft as a leader Teddy
Roosevelt can provide the Americans with
a combat bonus for fighting on their
home continent he also has the Rough
Riders as a unique unit these mounted
troops are effective in Hills game
culture from kills on their home
continent and have a low maintenance
cost both of America's unique military
units come into play after the
industrial era the Americans are a
powerful cultural sieve which shines in
the middle and late game tourism is key
to winning a cultural victory and
America has two unique traits that can
help it here the film studio is a unique
building that boosts the American
tourism output during the modern era
Teddy Roosevelt also gives a tourism
bonus to America's national parks which
makes them stronger than the parks of
other SIVs with these advantages the
other sips will be wearing blue jeans
and listening to your pop music as
America cruises towards a cultural
victory are you ready to take up the
limelight of the silver screen how will
you lead America to victory in Sid
Meier's Civilization six